haters gonna hate but John Cena isn't
putting up with it he has some harsh
words for anyone who says it's time for
the fast Saga to reach the Finish Line
The Fast and Furious franchise currently
consists of 11 movies a TV show and a
theme park ride the franchise kicked off
in 2001 and since then the Vin Diesel
LED Series has evolved into a
cross-cultural juggernaut as such some
people believe that the Saga has
overstayed its welcome and think it
should end as a result however John Cena
who plays Jacob Toretto in F9 and past X
isn't one of those critics Cena recently
sat down with extra and discussed the
longevity of a fast and furious
franchise he compared its ongoing
success to one of WWE's longest running
annual events noting that people are
fine with ongoing brand events if the
quality is strong he said having just
performed at the 39th installment of
WrestleMania My Philosophy is as long as
it's good that's all that matters fast
can continuously and you got box office
data to back it up continuously
entertains the world installation after
installation The Fast and Furious movies
always deliver at the box office
indicating that plenty of moviegoers
want to keep living life a quarter mile
at a time to date the franchise has
grossed over 6 billion dollars for
Universal Pictures with such steady box
office receipts especially in
international markets it's no surprise
that the past fam and Studio want to
continue their Cash Cow to the very end
that being said Cena believes that
people who want to see the franchise run
out of gas are misinformed about what
goes on behind the scenes Cena is used
to lending his talents to misunderstood
art forms with Fast and Furious he's
part of an over-the-top action franchise
that some people have grown tired of
tanning cars meanwhile as a wrestler
he's been criticized for participating
in a sport that has predetermined
outcomes and soap opera-esque storylines
at the end of the day the car chase Saga
and WWE are vastly different entities
but Cena has noticed some similarities
between their respective critics I
compare it to a fan who says but isn't
wrestling fake
they just don't understand what we do
and they just don't understand what this
is about the fast deck star went on to
say that these films deserve to keep
being made as long as the quality
remains exceptional and fans keep
demanding more installments Cena
concluded by saying that the naysayers
of The Fast and Furious franchise in WWE
have the right to express their views
however he reiterated that their
criticisms don't consider the
perspective of the fans and performers
despite what franchise naysayers and
haters say Fast and Furious has more
than enough gas left in its tank to
continue on for several more years a
sequel to fastx with director Louis de
Terrier will race into Cinemas in 2025
with a script co-penned by The Flash
writer Christina Hodson according to
franchise Stewart Vin Diesel fast 11
isn't the end of the road for Dominic
Toretto and his ever expanding family
should Diesel's wishes manifest
audiences will also receive a fast 12
which should close out the trilogy set
up by past X could there be even more
Fast and Furious beyond that that's
anyone's guess but Cena's right box
office receipts do dictate the future of
the franchise if audiences continue to
show up for more of the Toretto Clans
Shenanigans the franchise will live on
will that future include John Cena man I
hope so that's way above my pay grade
foreign
[Music]